توج المنتخب العراقي للمره الرابعه في
تاريخ بلقب بطل كاس الخليج بنسخته ال 25
اللي انتهاء يوم الخميس بفوز المنتخب
العراقي على نظيره العماني وعمت الفرحه
بالفوز كل الارجاء العراق كونوا من 35 عام
ما قدر يحصل فريق اسود الرافدين على اللقب
ولكن الفرحه بالفوز تحولت من احتفالات الى
انتقادات وجدل على المنصات من بعد تنظيم
الحشد الشعبي لحفل التكريم المنتخب او حفل
لتكريم المنتخب واللي صار في الحفله كمان
والعرفان قليله بحقكم يا اسود الرافدين
[موسيقى]
شكرا شكرا من اعماق القلوب شكرا بحجم
الفرح والمسرات
قلي
لا بحود الرافدين
[موسيقى]
شكرا شكرا من اعماق القلوب شكرا بحجم
الفرح والمسرات
عراقيون يعني استفزهم جدا انه ميليشيا
الحشد الشعبي بتقرر تكرم المنتخب واعتبروا
انه يعني من فين لفين يقرروا يكرم المنتخب
وبصفتهم ايش يعني واللي زاد الطين بلغ
شعره للدنيا اكثر هو رفع حارس مرمى
المنتخب جلال حسن لصوره ابو مهدي المهندس
النائب السابق لرئيس الحشد الشعبي واللي
انقتل في غاره جويه قرب مطار بغداد في
2020 وهو برفقه قائد فيلق القدس التابع
للحرس الثوري الايراني
الحفل كله محاوله من الحشد الاختطاف انجاز
وطني وحساب هذا الانجاز لنفسه وانتقدوا
رفع الصور المهندس بدل من رفع الكاس وعلم
العراق عراقي كمان غضبوا من لاعبين
المنتخب وخصوصا حارس المرمى اللي اعتبر
انه بايدوشيات مسلحه مدعومه من ايران
واعتبروا انه اللاعبين والاداره ولائهم
لايران بدل ما يكون للعراق وانهم كده ما
بيمثل الوطن الشريحه واحده
وينضم الينا دكتور باسل حسين الباحث
السياسي العراقي اهلا فيك معانا دكتور
باسل يعني حضرتك زينا اتفرجت على هذا
المقطع وهذا الاحتفال ايش رايك فيه
هناك محاوله من قبل
العام
ومن ضمن هذا الفضاء العام حقيقه الجوانب
رياضيه اقتصاديه سياسيه وتاتي محاوله
توظيف هذا
الانتصار العراقي اللي همم علاقه
عراقيه همم ايضا كانت هناك خيبه ايرانيه
همم او سواء من ايران او من وكلاء ايران
نتذكر الاعتراض الايراني على تسميه الخليج
العربي على كاس الخليج العربي
الاستقبال الحافل الفرق العربيه خلينا
نتذكر جيده انه حافله المنتخب السعودي
يتوقفت لي 45 دقيقه
يعني الحفاوه الكبيره للجمهور العراقي
الحافله سعود الفريق السعودي
العربي
لانه هو كان ما
ال 15 يوم اسقطت ما عملت عليه ايران طوال
20 سنه بعد انه عملت محاوله فصل العراق عن
البيئه العربيه لكن على حين غير وجد
الايرانيه انفسهم ان هنالك يعني
يعني حب جاري في الاستقبال الحفاوه
بالعرب والعوده والاشتياق
وكلهم يقولون نحن نشتاق الى العرب الى اخر
هذه بالتاكيد كان عامل ازعاج سواء
الايراني
يعني الاستعاده ما تم خسارته في اثناء
البطوله اعتقد انه بالتاكيد انه يعني ردود
الافعال اللي همم صدرت من الجمهور العراقي
هذا تاكيد يعني ضمن السياق العام على رفض
هذا يعني التدخل ايران او بالنسبه وكلاء
يعني اعتقد نتيجه طبيعيه المحاوله توظيف
في السياسه واست ما خسرته ايران وكلاء
ايران ومثل ما قلت كانت فتره 15 يوم فتره
تحديد واضحه لعمق العلاقه العربيه
الدكتور باسل بس خلينا نتكلم كمان على
الغضب الموجه
للمنتخب ولاعبين المنتخب وتحديدا كمان
بزياده حارس
المرمى هل انت بتشوف انهم يعني همم تم
توريتهم في هذا الموضوع ولا انه لا يجب
القاء اللوم عليهم ايضا لمشاركتهم في هذا
الاحتفال
لا نعتقد انه اللاعبين مغلوبه على يعني
امرهم يعني حقيقه وايضا هناك يعني الادراك
المستوى الثقافي يعني كثير من الامور اللي
داخلت يعني تعرفين همم يعمل في داخل
العراق يعني
يضع في جانبه رهانات حتى يعني الخوف حتى
من استبعاد المنتخب لانه هناك ربما يمكن
حتى يتم محاربتهم المنتخب
لموازنه الحسابات وبالتاكيد يعني اللاعبين
العراقيين اللاعبين وطنيين شعارنا حبهم
لهذا الوطن
عراقي تحديدا في كل المعاصر يعني اعتقد
انه ربما حادثه
خطا من قبل اللاعبين لكن اللاعبين لا يمكن
حقيقه يعني يعني بس هم في هذه المجال
همم ميديا كاتبين كمان كانوا بيتكلموا انه
في وسط كل الاحتفاء بالبطوله والاشياء
اللي صارت واو واو واو جاء هذا المشهد
وانه هذا المشهد هيخرب كيف كان المش-
العالم بيشاهد العراق خلال هذه الايام ايش
رايك في هذا الموضوع انه منظر هذا
الاحتفال وحمل صوره ابو مهدي المهندس
بالنسبه لبقيه العالم الخارجي
عمليه محاوله عمليه توظيف سياسي همم من
قبل الحشد لهؤلاء اللاعبين واللاعبين
تمزجهم في هذه المنزله همم
حول فوز المنتخب كثير من الزيارات
الاخيريه حتى يعني نزلت قلت اني يعني
حقيقه مقهوره على المدرب الاجنبي اللي ما
يعرف يعني همم من هو هؤلاء ربما حتى
ولماذا هم يعني يتم زيارتهم والى اخره
يعني هذا حتى خارج نطاق يعني عقده
وبالتالي اكثر
سياسيه ربما هذه الزيارات متعبه على النحو
يعني مضحك حقيقي
دكتور باسل حسين الباحث السياسي العراقي
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]